Amen.
Amen. Amen. You can have a seat, church. What a day.
It's a great day.
And so if you've been around this summer, you know
that we are walking phrase by phrase through Romans 12.
And what we're looking at is what a, a life transformed
by Christ actually looks like day to day.
Uh, what is that? Uh, that offering of our lives to God
as a living sacrifice
because of what Jesus has done, we offer ourselves to him.
How do we then realign our lives?
Not to conform to the world's way,
but to the way Jesus lived his life.
So we're looking at all of the aspects of life
that show up like that.
And so the last couple weeks, what we've seen is
how we can rejoice in hope, even while we endure tragedy,
suffering, trials, tribulations.
Well, it's interesting because in that verse,
there are three phrases.
Romans 12 verse 12. It, it says, rejoice in hope.
Be patient in tribulation. Be constant in prayer.
It's like those three are tied together,
that the way we apprehend the joy
through the suffering is through prayer.
That's how we clinging to, it's how we hold onto it.
And so that's what we're gonna look at today. That's it.
And really, it's an interesting
word in the original language.
Be constant is one word.
And that word is used a few times in the New Testament.
And it talks about persistence
that you are continuing to do.
You're devoted to an action.
You're gonna do it over and over.
You're disciplined in a way that is going to be a part
of your normal life's rhythm.
It's used in Acts 2 42 where the church was devoted.
The early church devoted themselves to prayer.
Acts six, four were the, the original elders, the apostles.
They said, we need to devote ourselves to prayer.
They were committed to it.
The early church was giving attention to prayer
that this was something they do.
Which by the way, is a challenge to all of us.
You ask any group of Christians, what are the things
that you need to grow in, things you need to get kind
of work on in your Christian life?
And prayer will always be one of the top.
This is one of the weakest parts of our Christian lives.
How little we devote ourselves, give attention to prayer.
But it's interesting as we think about that phrase,
be constant, how the King James version translated this
verse, because they were using Latin, uh,
manuscripts and things like that.
And, and the way it says it in King James version
is continuing instant in prayer.
Now, we don't speak like that.
It's really hard for us to understand sometimes
how the King James phrase things.
But, but we've modernized it to be constant in prayer.
Continuing instant though, our, our shift to modern
language has kind of lost something.
I think because you think continuing instant,
there's an urgency to it.
Like instant is now. It's today, right now we have to do it.
We can't not do it.
Continuing instant in prayer is
what the early church was doing, right?
They had to pray. There was no other option.
They had to do it. Now, it was urgent. It must be instant.
It must be the default. It was their go-to.
They had no other option. It was their first step.
Is that for us? Is that the first step for us?
Sadly, I don't think it is.
We have so many resources at our disposal and,
and we, we live our lives.
Now, we would never say this,
but we live our lives as if we don't really need God.
We don't need 'em at all. We just live our lives now.
Now, one of our churches' values that we,
we recognize this a couple years ago.
We reshaped our values as a church.
And one of them is called desperate dependence.
Desperate dependence is that we rely on the Holy Spirit
to empower our lives
and the church as we humbly abide in Jesus,
recognizing that we can do nothing on our own, right?
That that's what we want to do. But is it really true of us?
Like it's kind of an aspirational value,
meaning we wanna be that.
We want to do that, but we really honestly don't.
How often in our lives and,
and really times in our church, how often do we jump
to pragmatic solutions rather than desperate dependence?
We, we have all the options. We can make it happen.
We can put enough resources to this.
We can have enough programs to do this.
And so we jump to that stuff rather than depending on God
to do what only he can do.
I had somebody ask me a question
as a young pastor 15 years ago.
They asked the question, if the Holy Spirit was removed from
your church, would anything change?
Like the, are we trusting God to do what only God can do?
Or are we so good at doing all the things ourselves
that we wouldn't even recognize if he was gone?
It can't be that, right?
It must be devoted to dependence,
desperate dependence on God.
And so what we wanna do
as a church is we wanna realign our lives
with Christ's perfect standard.
Like, like, we're gonna try to move
that direction by his power.
And so we know,
and listen, I know I'm gonna say baby
steps a couple times here.
Some of you're like, I'm way past baby steps.
Let's just be honest. If we're not Jesus yet,
we still have room to grow.
Okay? So, so don't get, don't think too highly of yourself.
Like there's ways you can grow
and maybe you're thinking you're
further along than you really are.
I do that all the time, that I'm further,
I know I'm actually, I'm really not.
If I'm just doing this.
I think I'm here, but I'm actually here.
And so we're gonna take some baby steps to grow in this.
We're gonna practice prayer today.
And then we're gonna take a couple other
steps outside of this.
Because if this must be a habit, this must be a rhythm.
And if it's gonna be one of those, if it's gonna be a habit,
it's gotta go beyond this room.
It can't just be in here
that every Sunday we gather and we do this.
Okay, great. If it's gonna be a rhythm in our lives,
realign our lives, it's gotta be something more.
And so that's why today we are kicking off
what we're calling the 1212 prayer initiative.
1212 prayer initiative.
I asked my sons yesterday if they could figure out why we
called it 12.
12. And it took a little while, but we got there.
Romans 1212 says,
be constant in prayer.
So we're super creative around here.
We're gonna call it 1212 prayer initiative, right?
So that's what we're talking about this, this idea
of wanting to be constant in prayer.
We want to initiate something
that's gonna give us room to grow.
It's baby steps, but it's something to start with.
So here's what it is.
We've been reading the Bible together over
the last couple of months.
If you're getting that email, you see
that we've been reading the Bible together.
We also want to begin praying together more regularly.
Now, it doesn't mean all of us in the room together.
It means all of us at the same time together during the week
Thursdays at, can you guess the time?
12, 12:00 PM right?
So that's what we are going to begin
to build into the rhythm of our lives of our church,
the 12:12 PM on Thursdays, just for a few minutes maybe,
or for longer, just to devote ourselves more regularly
to prayer.
So here's how we're gonna kick this off.
I want you to, you have permission
to pull your phone out right now.
Maybe you left yours in the car.
That's some people's wise decision. I get that.
But make a note, you'll want to do this later.
Pull out your phone, whatever version
of whatever phone you have, find the alarms,
go find the alarms.
And what I am encouraging to you to do is to set an alarm
for Thursdays every Thursday at
12:12 PM I've got it on here.
Be constant in prayer is the title of it.
And I've got it set for every day.
You can set it for every day,
but at least, at least
Thursdays at 12:12 PM you set an alarm that reminds you
to be constant in prayer.
And that all of us,
the whole church is doing it at the same time.
There's something about the momentum with that.
But just think about what happens.
This, you set that alarm, you're at lunch and,
and you're, you're sitting there, your alarm goes off
and you have to make a decision
what you're gonna do with that.
What a witness to say to someone that you're with.
Say, Hey, listen, can we just stop for a moment?
I, I, I wanna, is there anything I can pray for you about?
But, but our church is praying at 12:12 PM on Thursdays.
I would love to pray for this thing that we've,
and I'll tell you about that in a second.
But, but what we've decided to pray for today,
can we just pray for a moment about that?
What a witness, right?
Like what a witness that would be to somebody
who has no idea and they think you're crazy,
but then you have a, an opportunity to share with them.
Or, or maybe, maybe you're bold
and you wanna start gathering a couple people together every
Thursday at 12:12 PM
and you say, Hey, let's do this every week together.
Let's gather five or six of us together.
Let's start praying at 1212 for our church, for ourselves,
for our lives, all of that.
That would be an incredible opportunity
because so many things in history
that God has done in big ways go back to a group of five
or six people praying together for God to move.
What can God do with a few people
praying together like that?
What should you pray? Well,
whatever the Lord brings to mind, of course.
But in my weekly Wednesday email,
I'm gonna begin including a section that has a scripture
or a prayer point
that we will all then pray together on that Thursday.
So you got a 24 hour, we send it at Route noon on Wednesday,
and you could get it then a day to look at it
before that Thursday.
Now, if you don't get my email on Wednesdays,
that would be important for you to get then, right?
Like, so what we're gonna do is on the, uh, QR code,
on the seat back in front of you, it takes you to a website
that we have that you can sign up for it there.
You can also go to hhbc.com/connect on the notes.
You'll see it there. It's all there.
You can go sign up for that email
because that's how we're gonna distribute
what you can, what you can pray for.
Now, you can pray for whatever you want,
but we're saying you can pray for these things
that we're going to intentionally as a church, pray
for each week on that Thursday,
because again, be constant in prayer.
We want to grow in that.
It's a baby step, at least Thursdays, if not every day
baby steps towards growth into Christ's likeness
where we're breathing in God's word.
We're breathing out prayer and praise.
We're breathing in God's word,
breathing out prayer and praise.
So we're doing that today to practice.
That's what Thursdays at 1212 is about.
Wherever you are doing it together,
knowing we're all doing it at the same time,
that is really powerful.
So I wanna pray just briefly for God's blessing on that.
We feel like he led us to that.
And so we wanna make sure, uh, we're giving it to him.
Lord, we do need you.
We pray in desperate dependence,
you would do something with this.
It's, it's just a simple act, God.
But, but we do see the example Jesus, you set
of being constant in prayer.
The early church set in being devoted to prayer.
God, we want to be more of that.
And so, Lord, just take this one step further towards
alignment with you, that our lives
and our hearts are, are oriented and geared towards you.
Help us Lord. In Jesus' name we pray. Amen.
And so if you notice today, we started with a prayer
of praise by singing name above all names.
We read the scripture, Psalm 95,
which was a song or a prayer.
We're gonna pray now. We started with praise.
We're gonna pray now by waiting on God.
Prayer's a two way street. It's a communication with God.
And if you know communication one way,
communication is not really that effective.
Doesn't build a relationship.
And so we have to then wait and listen to God.
The primary way God speaks is in his word.
That's first and foremost.
But with his spirit inside of you believer,
he also then will impress things upon you by his spirit.
Things that will not necessarily be audible words,
but direction or, or maybe wisdom
or what steps to take or or clarity on the situation.
God will do that through your waiting on him.
So I'm gonna read Psalm 62, which talks about this.
It's on your notes. You can look at it later.
It's on the screens as well.
But we're gonna practice this idea of waiting
quietly on the Lord.
So listen to what Psalm 62 says, for God alone, oh my soul,
wait in silence.
For my hope is from him.
He only is my rock
and my salvation, my fortress, I shall not be shaken
on God rest my salvation and my glory, my mighty rock.
My refuge is God.
Trust in him at all times.
Oh, people pour out your heart before him.
God is a refuge for us. Sayah.
So like that word sayah means,
let's now leave some quiet space listening for
that still small voice of God running to him as a refuge.
Let's do that now.